from The Daily Mail Russia plans false
flag attack on hydroelectric Dam to
flood Curson in latest attack on energy
plants as Ukraine brings in four hour
blackouts to tackle electricity
shortages so that's bad now what they're
saying is General Sergey Sarah viken
Russia's new supreme commander in
Ukraine has spoken to Russian media in
recent days but what he called the
devastating strike on the Nova kakovka
Dam which he said was being plotted by
kev's troops siriviken who has also been
preparing the Russian public for a
retreat from the region said the blast
would flood Kirsten and cause widespread
damage they go to mention in the article
that according to experts from the study
of War it's actually them prepping us to
accept a false flag attack because
what's really happening is they're
saying hey look they're going to attack
us then they blow the dam knocking out
power in the region retreating and then
blaming Ukraine for it who do you
believe
yeah that's you go ahead you wanted to
say something before
you know I I've studied Russia and the
Soviet Union and now Russia for 30 some
years and that they're they think half
European and half asian I mean underfoot
like you said actually in both camps
it's just like kind of like with China I
mean they are sometimes Oriental in
their thinking uh Indiana for Putin it's
about his survival his power base and
after that was better for his vision for
Russia yeah I covered this story uh in
my earlier video today on my channel and
it's the United States and U.S Intel
saying Russia is going to launch a false
flag attack to uh flood this Russia is
saying the same thing on their state
television and everything they're saying
is almost the same exact thing except
you reverse the major actors here
they're saying the United States is
going to be launching a false flag
attempt and we've seen this kind of
rhetoric heat up especially today which
uh you know is concerning to to say the
least but uh Anything could happen I
think we should always be skeptical but
when it comes to this larger War we have
to understand that there's also
unconventional warfare what happened to
Nordstrom wasn't an accident and I think
we have to look at our infrastructure as
as it's also a potential Target for the
Russians or the Chinese or even third
parties that could intervene and say hey
it could be in our interest to spark up
this conflict make it a bigger conflict
and it might not even be Russia or the
United States that could set up a false
flag it could be a third party uh a
country or another special group that
comes in there and it's like okay fight
each other as we rise to power so
obviously the concern is as a
humanitarian crisis so we have the
deeper Rivers cut off the Russian troops
so of course that are on in the Garrison
side of the west side of the river the
ukrainians are Poise they've knocked out
most of the bridges the Russians are
resupplying with pontoons and boats and
what have you that can't be sustained
for long combat operations so when if
there's Russian forces tracked I think
that dam is going down no matter what uh
what's surprising to me in the in my
early days in the army that the Soviets
the Russians were far better at this
information and information operations
than they are today Putin has two
audiences the international audience and
and of course is domestic his domestic
audience thinks he's fantastic he's got
the 80 some percent you know positives
despite the bad news does he really
though
how much can we trust of their media
according to try falgar
yeah I I do think he tends to be popular
I mean he's the Macho Man you know we
know how they have an image ingrained in
our brains you know in a t-shirt on the
back of it he has he has higher approval
numbers because he turned Russia from an
international joke to to a place that of
course made sure that people weren't
drinking all the time one of the biggest
reasons why Putin is as popular as he is
is because he's not drunk all the time
like the previous leader was exactly
and and then when you see you see him
reprimand people who do get drunk who
are in the factories who are in in you
know a major institutions of power in in
Russia he makes an example out of them
and even when there's occasions to have
a drink or have a shot or have cheers
he's like no I'm not doing it so so
that's you know one reason why people
see him as this kind of you know savior
to to Russia and their interests and
their country uh but at the end of the
day it's just another politician and how
long can he last with losses and
casualties stacking up in Afghanistan
you know eight years later on eight
years of a war with Afghanistan they
finally withdrew in 1989 I mean but this
is this is Russia's strategy hasn't it
always been just send ridiculous amounts
of your troops and until you just
overwhelm your your opponents that has
been their approach since World War
actually since World War one yeah not in
Vietnam they were happy to fight The
Limited War by sending arms into Vietnam
I think after World War II they realize
it's just not a tenable way to fight
proxy wars using allies against the
United States and then that flipped in
the 80s when Reagan started using
proxies in Latin American elsewhere and
Africa as well and and then in
Afghanistan where we you know we've
kindly realized we don't have to do all
the fighting here so you know the
policeman of the world remember that I
mean that notion from some years ago
limited War it was a Henry Kissinger
Doctrine yes that they kind of
instituted Vladimir Putin is using you
know this this culture War rhetoric
there's a lot of people who feel that in
the west right now we've got these
degenerate deviant and just abhorrent
ideologies emerging from the left
Vladimir Putin seems to be capitalizing
that outright calling out this stuff as
Satanism and so there are a lot of
people in the US who think he's actually
this it's this great Christian Nation
fighting back against evil and
degeneracy yeah he's also speaking out
against child conversion therapy right
and but is this is this him realizing
There's an opportunity to propagandize
or does he actually believe the things
he's saying well I mean he has a problem
on his hands because I know he wants to
identify that as traditionally Russia
but Russia Today is is more is becoming
more and more increasingly Muslim than
it is Christian or european yeah so you
know what is Russia Today I think that's
it's hard to get our minds around you
know in America but I think that's part
of his his land grab with you know south
of Kazi and Georgia and now in eastern
Ukraine they're ethnic Russians but
something really went wrong since 2014
Lionel Rich Putin is has managed to
forge a Ukrainian identity whether
you're ethnic Ukrainian or ethnic
Russian they now identify fully as
Ukraine most of them there's always
exceptions I was uh I was there when the
my Dan protest started and so I was
hanging out it was awesome food was
great uh I saw the burn the building
that they set on fire that I was uh I
got to see the statue that they'd pull
down of Lenin yeah it was a long
complicated story and how that all went
down but I met a lot of these people a
lot of young people and they all
basically said the same thing we
remember what it was like under the
Soviet Union and we never want to go
back so there are a lot of people who
talk about the eastern region and it's
probably true for in the East a lot of
people who are ethically Russian they
speak Russian and view themselves as
more Russian but then you're going to
end up with a split in the country from
people who are like I remember the
Soviets you know we're not happy with
that and then they're gonna be a lot of
people who are just like I don't trust
the West I don't like their ideology you
remember and that's interesting because
you know their grandparents lived
through the hollow mode however you say
it the the four starvation yeah that's
it in what 32-33 over the winter and
seven to ten million we don't even know
how many died ukrainians and it happened
in other countries
I mean it's a tough situation and the
Putin is stuck now he didn't have his
decisive knockout blow he did not get
zelinski he did not take Kiev and uh now
he's stuck in his fight I'm just
surprised I mean there are a lot of
people who firmly believe Putin is
winning I I think that's just not true I
know there's propaganda and it really
annoys me like you pull up American
social media in every single video is
like some Ukrainian Soldier flicking a
cigar being like and I'm like come on
like I know they're not winning every
single fight you know but but you look
at where the the major news is breaking
where the major moves are happening
happening and what Putin's doing and
like yeah they're getting pushed out but
there's a lot of people who just I
suppose they don't want to believe it
they want to believe that you know
Russia is winning he's advancing Ukraine
is is is not winning my thought on this
is just did Putin not realize that NATO
was going to be it was going to be a
proxy war with NATO I mean you you have
Russian pundits saying since the
beginning of this I think like in March
they're like we're at war with NATO okay
did he think he was going to win that
we're providing intelligence we're
providing weapons training not only that
our citizens volunteers and now we're
learning from The Intercept actual U.S
Special Operations on the ground in in
Ukraine why would Putin think he's going
to go up against NATO and win is it a
last stand or what is it yeah I think he
underestimated uh the resolve the
ukrainians which I did too as well I'm
surprised at the area of beat back the
air assault Airborne forces and then you
know overestimated his own forces on
paper good army pretty modernized you
know the front line forces but look what
happened I mean but this also betrays a
point here we have to in Pennsylvania
plays a role in this I mean energy yeah
so we're now in this energy crisis here
we're told gas prices growing up because
of Putin that's that's Biden's line
uh but Pennsylvania has the resources to
become a leader in energy in the world
with our natural gas we have one of the
largest natural gas deposits in around
the globe we have great high quality
coal we have high quality oil so my goal
is as governor of course is to make us
number one in energy production
there's a hundred billion dollars of
potential wealth out there to be
received by Pennsylvania if we can
produce that much you know it's all
about you know the capability my goal is
to have a pipeline
to Philly out to Delaware so we can
start exporting to Boston because Boston
had to bring in Russian ships in 2018
and they called one do you remember the
madness because of the pipe there's no
pipelines from Pennsylvania so they
brought in two ships from Siberia four
thousand miles away so I want to be able
to support uh Boston but maybe export
also to Germany get them off of Russian
oil and gas and maybe our friends in
Poland and for sure the lithuanians have
already you know committed that they
wanted to buy it off of Pennsylvania I
was willing to entertain a lot of this
go green stuff for a while but the
moment you come out and say you know Joe
Biden says he wants to get get us off
fossil fuels he says it was part of his
campaign when he ran for president then
he shuts down Keystone then he bans
fracking in certain areas and then he
goes to Saudi Arabia and begs for oil
I'm like it's not about getting it's not
about stopping fossil fuels I don't know
what the actual uh why actually let me
just ask you
how does this make sense that we got to
stop using fossil fuels and then he he
hurts the United States and then goes
over to Saudi Arabia and begs them to
keep up production so we can keep
getting fossil fuels what's what's the
reasoning then when we were entered
energy independent and gas was under two
bucks a gallon 184. 184 just just less
than what two years ago just over two
years ago and now we're begging the
Saudis and even go to the Venezuelans
and kind of winking and nodding to the
Iranians are you kidding me and and
exporting our wealth over these foreign
countries who aren't really that
friendly I mean we have a good relation
with the Saudis because of necessity
because who's around them and it's a
rough neighborhood but Pennsylvania
United States ought to be energy
independent and that's one thing you
know this is the age of Governors you
know I'm glad you've brought other
candidates on the show here Pennsylvania
could lead the way in making America
energy independent once again why you
think it is that they're advocating for
no energy Independence at home while
begging others for energy I mean do we
just not understand or or is it just I
wonder if it's that Democrat rats know
their base wants environmentalism but
they also know you can't have cheap gas
and environmentalism so they're just
lying
I think it's exactly that I think
they're driven by a gross ideology here
that that's making life harder more
expensive than the Working Class People
the Democrats claim they represent hey
yeah let me let me let me jump to the
story real quick but it's really good
before doing that you know they got to
build back better somehow what better
way than to destroy the previous version
of it and and I really wanted to ask you
a question doug because the Obama the
Biden Administration has specifically
stopped domestic energy exploration and
production will they stand in your way
as governor and can they stop you from
doing what you want to do in state
that's that's my Valley Way on state
lands I completely control that on
private lands with the cooperation of
Atlantis I don't know if we have time I
get a four-prong approach it's called
the Pennsylvania energy Independence act
it's not a gimmick it's actually I
developed this with the energy sector
and of course we want to do it
responsibly we want to do it cleanly we
want our trout being killed and
poisoning our land obviously we want
cancer causing agents and the energy
sector has proven they can do it you
know better the first part of course is
a rolling back uh our entry into this
Regional greenhouse gas initiative
Reggie which is a carbon tax it's
increased it's doubled almost our cost
of energy in Pennsylvania starting the
first of June so on day one we're going
to be out of it when I'm sworn in on 17
January and you'll see immediate relief
for the working class people out there
savings and energy so it's not a choice
between Heating and eating part two of
that of course is rolling back about
eight years of regulations from our
Department of Environmental Protection
within Pennsylvania that have gone too
far because it's it's so restrictive
that they're driving energy uh
businesses to Ohio West Virginia and
Texas and I want them back in
Pennsylvania and then of course I talked
about the pipeline one coming at across
from from Pittsburgh area to Philly and
I'll bring lots of great jobs I'll bring
uh security as far as energy goes it
will improve it for NATO and then also
I'd like to see a pipeline
towards Lake Erie and so uh and then of
course I'll open up State lands and do
doing that we I can do I can do all that
without being in uh stopped by the EPA
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there